we've just seen this pop up on the
government website in the last few
minutes that um
you may be able to temporarily leave
quarantine for covid in england
if you are a senior executive in a
business undertaking activities
likely to be of significant economic
benefit and they define that as
preserving 500 jobs in the uk i'm not
sure how you
would prove that they say it's a special
exemption and
not not going to be used as a loophole
for everyone but i think it's just gonna
just like the um the incident with the
ua for officials being able to leave
quarantine
i think it's just going to fuel this
feeling that ordinary people are having
to
follow the rules and a special elite of
people are having the rules
bent for them and it's going to increase
even if it's hardly anyone is going to
be able to take advantage of it
it will increase pressure on the
government to just to sort out a testing
alternative
to self-isolation especially when you're
looking at people who've had
two vaccinations